We were going to Puerto Rico from California and we had a layover in New York,...
...and we got caught in a blizzard.
So, we had to sleep in the airport the first night,...
...and they apologized,...
...but there was nothing we could do...
...and we were waiting for them to get us a new flight...
...and they put us in a hotel and, of course, we didn't pay for it,...
...but it was extremely dull and boring...
...and we were fifteen minutes from Manhattan, one of the most interesting cities.
And well, we were all packed for a sunny, Caribbean weather...
...even though it was Christmas time.
And we had no warm clothes,...
...so we couldn't go out in the blizzard and we stayed there for two days...
...and then we slept a fourth day in the airport again...
...until we finally went over to Puerto Rico,...
...but the beginning of that trip was horrible.